elle est venue nous retrouver avec une
presse une presse qui pèse plus de 100
kg c'est bien ça oui c'est bien ça une
tresse en foot
une presse à l'épreuve qui sert à
imprimer des épreuves de textes en
général mais elle sert aussi à un privé
des gravures et donc 100 kg tu la
trimballe pas comme ça non je la prends
pas de mon sac et gravures dans les prix
c'est sympa de la vendée juste pour nous
oui
bon alors tu fais de la typographie du
fait de la gravure d'ailleurs c'est là
dessus que tu es en train de travailler
puisque tu prépares l'oeuvre que tu va
nous présenter ce soir je regarde pas
trop où on va en parler dans un instant
mais qu'est ce que c'est la typographie
aujourd'hui la typographie aujourd'hui
c'est l'assemblage de l'être
mobile pour créer des textes et des mots
et on les imprime avant c'était vraiment
ce qu'ils utilisaient les imprimeurs
pour imprimer les journaux les cartes de
visite les faire-part etc
maintenant on s'en sert toujours pour la
même chose mais plus orienté
vers des éditions deluxe des éditions
qui ont un rendu un peu plus artistique
est alors toi tu travailles comme une
finalement un peu comme butin berck ya
rien qui est automatisé non mais t'es
complètement à contre-courant de
l'époque parce que c'est vrai qu'on n'a
jamais autant écrit qu' aujourd'hui des
mails des sms mais c'est des choses qui
s'évapore alors que toi tu les graves
dont justement m'envoie des textes comme
ça c'est justement pour les filles c'est
un livre qui va prendre le temps d'être
d'âcre et d'être imprimé puis un livre
qu'on va qu'on va donner à quelqu'un que
l'on aime ou qu'on va conseiller en lui
disant voilà regardant le travail qui
est fait c'est un travail manuel
tout est fait à la main et on sait le
temps c'est de l'amour en fait ça en
fait complètement vers le thème de cette
émission c'est le clash des époques les
anciens qui dialoguent avec les modernes
donc toi c'est un peu ton pain quotidien
alors qu'est ce que tu as décidé de nous
faire pour pour ce soir sachant que tu
es plutôt partition de la gravure qui
était votre wii spécialité alors là
c'est plutôt je suis parti pour réaliser
une vanité contemporaine et ancien avec
des techniques qui confie un peu les
deux dedans il ya ce qu'on appelle le
dot qui est plutôt une quelque chose qui
utilisait pour faire du tatouage et puis
l'autre côté il ya vraiment de la
gravure le traditionnel et pas de date
le dot c'est tout ce que tu vas voir
apparaître là c'est des petits
pointillés qui vont venir créer une
image alors que là c'est vraiment de la
gravure traditionnel où on vient enlever
les blancs pour pour créer du noir en
fait voilà ce qui est d'assez génial
c'est qu'en fait là on se rend pas
compte non mais après comment tu vas
faire forer valeur de f1 a pris on va
prendre de lancre grâce qui est là bas
on va en créer toute la plaque
et puis on va mettre
un pied dessus on va le passer en presse
et puis le résultat va se faire c'est un
peu comme en photo en fait ça va se
révéler au moment où je ferme mon
premier tirage en fait tout ce que tu
creuses c'est ce qui n'apparaîtrait pas
à la pression ouais ouais d'accord tout
ce qu'on creuse en fait c'est blanc tout
ce que je laisse va paraître en noir ou
dans la couleur dans laquelle tu choisis
d'un prime était intégrée
en fait c'est comme un tampon en fait tu
fabriques un tampon classiquement si tu
mets un miroir au dessus tu vas pouvoir
voir ce à quoi ça ressemble réellement
parce que là elle est en négatif mais
quand je vais l'imprimé ça va devenir
positif